Ngoài 2020 thành hai năm 2020, công an tỉnh Lâm Đồng đã ra quy định hợi tụ hủ an,
hợi tổ bị cân và lạnh tạm ra đời với phản Quốc Huy,
xin năm 2019, chú phần tinh thành tỉnh Lâm Đồng để đưa trà về tổ vi phản quy định về thân ra ra thông đường bộ.
Theo kết quả đưa trà, và khoảng không dự bốn phút ngày 2020,
sau khi sự dụng giữ biệt, phản Quốc Huy vẫn điều khiến xe autobahn tại tả Mi Sao Sê, một bẩy khu sảo tảm.
Hì đến gát tư rò nhau giữa đường đến tất thành và đường tốt đức tháng,
phung phản thiết, giờ thử chú ý của sát và không giảm tốc độ,
xe của Huy đã và trảm với xe mấy sọng lửa vyss sê, chú phung phản thiết, điều khiến,
sau khi người tài nạn, Huy không dừng xe để đưa nạn nhân đi cấp cứu,
mà tích tục điều khiến xe autobahn là xe mấy hơn năm 2019,
hậu qua, ông xe bị thương nọ, đưa đi cấp cứu, nhưng đã tử vong giờ tư tích quá nọ.
Quả kiểm tra, nông độ cùng trong mẫu của phản Quốc Huy là 1,2 mẹ phy tả Mi Sao Mi đi gàm đe lượng.
Bán phòng cơ quan cạnh rất đưa chạy công an tỉnh lưng đồng đang tích tục đưa chạy,
làm só của an theo quy định của pháp lần.